good morning John so I'm watching a
scary thing happen not just in my
country but with my peers and my friends
it's fairly new I think since that all
expertise is false you can't trust the
government of the media or scientists or
even charities everything is fake we get
a dozen questions a week on dear Hank
and John from people who start out
saying look I know that I have to go to
the bottom of every single story myself
because of course you can't trust anyone
anymore that has become the case we are
absolutely screwed no one can get to the
bottom of everything in fact that's what
experts are for journalists and
international organizations and
scientists in the government these are
experts that have been tasked by society
with getting to the bottom of different
kinds of things and they are all groups
that more and more it seems we feel we
cannot trust what can we trust then well
mostly whatever narrative we've already
signed up for if things fit into it we
shot them around and if they don't we
quietly ignore them the causes of this
are plentiful it's human nature it's the
result of a fractured system of
information-sharing government has of
course and almost traditionally
deteriorated its own credibility by
focusing more on winning than governing
and news media has destroyed its own
credibility and also everyone else's by
focusing on cheap easy things that
people to gobble up like tea and mainly
opinion pieces and shouting matches
between people who are paid to disagree
with each other this is at least in part
because the financial model that
supported journalism as well as the
editorial control that newspapers once
had over what people saw first
simultaneously fell apart and we're on
the internet we very rarely look at a
front page we mostly look at what's on
our fee and what goes into a feed isn't
controlled by experts it's often
controlled by our worst instinct it
turns out when the hive mind decides
what's on the front page it becomes
drama and opinion and controversy and
demonization of the other and
self-congratulation and thus the
hotcakes have gotten so hot I'm worried
the whole country's gonna catch fire if
you actually pick up a physical
newspaper or magazine none of that's the
news the front page of an actual
mainstream newspaper or inside of a
magazine like The Economist what you
find is valuable expensive expert driven
truth-telling like who knew I'd forgot
important things about Venezuela or
Yemen or why Americans are dying younger
if you read peer-reviewed articles if
you find a politician who will actually
talk with you if you find a news source
that is mainstream and actually read the
news that's there Ryann large you find
that X
Burt's are actually experts look
sometimes reporting is bad or incomplete
or inflammatory if the wall street
journal publishes a piece that isn't
good reporting which they have that
doesn't mean that everything The Wall
Street Journal is garbage and it doesn't
really doesn't mean that everything in
every newspaper is garbage we should
hold journalists accountable for the
work that they do but we shouldn't just
throw them out we need them and feels
like we're starting to live in a world
where media critics are the news
themselves people who attack expertise
without any desire let alone ability to
replace expertise and thus we get the
high of feeling like we're better than
the experts without having to be experts
on anything except for like drama and
controversy I'm not saying that there
isn't a problem in news media that
there's nothing to be fixed but man am i
sick of watching people ignore the
tremendous amount of value that
journalists provide for our country and
our world the destruction of expertise
and all the terrible things that have
come with it from feeling personally ill
informed to electing a reality TV star
president to continuing to deny the
biggest crisis humanity has ever faced
is all our fault
it is at the very least my fault I
choose a preference for the op-eds and
the hot take I get confused about what
news is I look at what I read and I
think I can't trust the mainstream media
anymore but I am choosing to read the
crap they're providing the crap which
maybe they shouldn't but they have to
because it's what people read and if
they aren't getting it from mainstream
media they'll get it from the other guy
trustworthy journalism driven by
expertise is out there it's right where
nobody's gonna read it buried deep down
on the front page John I'll see you on
Tuesday